how's it going rez - mana back I thought
I was gonna finish this [ __ ] we are
gonna finish this sandwich but first we
will have to go back all the way to a
hundred good thing that doesn't take
forever
don't panic pets just be cool I can go
wherever I want but I guess I'm the
[ __ ] huh yeah that's okay I don't mind
doing that [ __ ] again I got the key do
that part down y'all [ __ ] that funny day
I can see the mouse I can [ __ ] see oh
oh
now let's just make it to a hundred oh
oh God okay I sending that means up no
apparently does not mean up you bros
told me it means up
Oh - of course
[ __ ] you
okay we're gonna do it gotta do it okay
[Music]
ABCDEF the holy the Parliament OPA QX
Lucetta hundred two [ __ ] let's do we
go go away go away go away go away go
away go I don't have time I don't just
thumbs up why do you have blood on your
mouth hundred three [ __ ] one hundred
three hundred what is oh god red Oh
color
I just guessed hundred for uh which one
which one what you I don't know what I'm
supposed to know the order yeah I'm
completely I'm just supposed to know
that check
oh come for you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of you I [ __ ]
hate what did I forget
oh god damn you did I cook I closed it
the things I do for you bras you don't
even know half of it
Oh deej a black don't distract me like
that I want to have one life now
seriously this is where I would start
becoming nervous I hate the alphabet is
this hard switching on and on from
English to Swedish not that it matters
it's just weird okay I was taught the
alphabet long before I know English okay
that should that that should be all of
them how many alphabets there's an
alphabet have that I forget something I
didn't that's the alphabet but apneic
dr. Carter you do the game I think
there's a balloon for every time this
quest took my virginity
there we are I don't know I don't know
why typing the [ __ ] alphabet is such
a [ __ ] little [ __ ] I'm just gonna
shut up and focus cuz I'm tired of this
[ __ ]
I don't Oh what did I god I don't even
know what happened go away go away go
away go away go away go away or away
he'll go away
okay you're red I don't know one knows
why oh oh if you stop her on that [ __ ]
it's like this is impossible without the
food stop aah all right what do we got
next
bring it on [ __ ] I'm Batman that was
upside down Search Search what is this
oh my eyes they burn why did he see some
kids they don't burn unless they're
haunted oh what's that oh it's easy
Oh God which cheese is made backwards
that's just I remembered all right
what's at 108 okay put your mouse on
there I don't want to I just cheat
what's up I'll [ __ ] but that's just
cheating cheesing cheating I try to make
a joke what is this that is question
[ __ ] graphite that's of [ __ ] how did ten
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] click the red square
oh god oh god where is it
darkness
chris says they're half-sheet Tabak
I didn't tab I didn't add I like this
clean so much fun writing other for the
other aliens time they looked like a
bunch of penises on the bowl okay okay
here we go
here we go oh god this one carefully I
remember I played it so many times man
you have no idea how many times I played
this [ __ ] [ __ ] put your mouse on
there oh God should I skip this one like
oh I did it okay but I lose alive come
on Bruns we can do it la Oh God okay
there there where the [ __ ] there well
there's so many you're gonna have fun it
oh thank Jesus I don't know what number
this is chris says oh yeah okay I wrote
this down tab bar plyatt plot oh space
it oh god that's good okay what happens
now what oh oh
click it I open it you saw I open it
everyone so I'd open a she saw I open it
I open it well I guess we gotta keep
going
no big deal
oh god I what I miss
Oh for [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] sake what did I
miss
I can't type oh I hate why it's the
first one man I would have been done
with this [ __ ] if it wasn't for the
first one main if it wasn't oh god why
why I gotta look at you while I do it
you [ __ ] maybe see Oh for [ __ ] sake I
skipped it um I I don't I can't the
panic the paddock unless you're having a
robotic arm I'm pretty sure this part is
impossible without the time thing
ahahahaha I don't know oh god I lose
alive when I do this one oh god [ __ ] you
when I do that one oh god my ass it
burns so hardly my ass and I haven't
even had spicy food that's the best way
to describe this game man
one man per alien really well I guess I
would explain my subscriber count'
honestly the quiz should just be over
there
that should just be over we go home we
go on with our life with Chris gotta
come in the picture okay I don't know
why typing the [ __ ] alphabet is so
[ __ ] hard
Oh via CN d e f g 4e g co l m n o p p q
r s u VX is a tough kid
I can't type the alphabet I'm officially
mentally challenged I'm actually okay
with it because nothing can be worse
than this I hate so many things right
now but not this moment if the body
wasn't there and what I mean how would I
understand what the alphabet is so
[ __ ] hard do i type too fast is that
it cuz I have to type fast Chris I'm
gonna skip it I don't give a [ __ ]
no God okay what now I don't remember
the food right the food okay take it
[Music]
serve it to Chris here's wearing it how
am I supposed to know after answered the
pasty requested it's a good one in
future the nicest color which color is
the nicest the same color that one okay
okay yeah I appreciate that you love
fresh fresh brush brush brush brush
brush brush brush brush brush brush
brush brush
holy [ __ ] I'm a dick I'm better than
that Caturday [ __ ] easy right now
[Music]
suck my you honey we're so close oh god
don't [ __ ] this one isn't even hard I
can't believe I [ __ ] feel like this
one it is the tight ass though it
expires oh yeah
oh god what are you gonna throw at my
face can I introduce you please to a
lump of shredded cheese as long as the
name is Trevor can I call a friend it's
a song I'm looking up the lyrics I'm
sorry I don't know American songs or
whatever hit one drop one that one
yes [ __ ] yeah Oh God 118 I'm not gonna
do that again 8 that is my computer I
need it I'll take got it how do you
defuse a frank baum force peanut she go
away it's 9 something come on Chris
this you're useless I will say this in
the nicest way possible this shocking
[ __ ] eating not exploding horse
penetration in your [ __ ] this game this
is by far the hardest game i have ever
[ __ ] played enjoy watching i am going
to shove a unicorn up my ass leave a
like if you enjoyed watching i hit
subscribe rise today breakfast
[Music]
you